hello and welcome to the CEO chess
commando was as my opponent yet another
ok head dead where do people play that
it's really not so great okay
this is just not right there anyway it's
not like it's lost or anything but it is
not good and this guy is playing like
crazy fast Bishop g4 is a completely
useless move
okay
since trade off but where do you go when
I'd be eight next
maybe I don't want to trade
again
are we going night b5 here
doesn't any much
hmm
you
hmm but unsure here what bear what's
best you know
see it's probably going to play a 6 a.m.
you
hmm I mean it's better for white but
it's tough to determine what's best you
know
well so night b5 is not very soon okay
I would be scared no he's not scared he
just plays a move
he's not scared so he traps one of my
pieces there for some ingenious idea
it's happening here
takes night eggs I don't see the big
trick so 96 now it is attacking deform
so he tries some miracle defense it
cannot work come on
some miracle defense I've got a five as
well where is this night Queen to c8
antigone b7 okay I should not play III M
that is not good
you see aiming for
he 5mm
you
no then I'm playing a fight
default covered that's covered before he
doesn't have a good move anyway at least
I don't seared Wow
so
oh come on such a bad player
I mean this is so friggin horrible I
should just loose material
don't see it
a five-night see a tick tick
if five queen d8 crazy
about hordes
before 98
totally terrible but it's summer [ __ ]
I don't know
you
need to need to make a move
got no time
you
makes it interesting position the
position is so awful
and maybe you can play like 98
and it's not lost right a8 I mean
as it looks I don't quite see how I'm
refuting it I can take p7
I don't know he never played a move I
expected yeah and it continues that way
so kind of useless to anticipate
what a crazy game
you
that should be in the end I mean have
nine seconds but I also have a piece
you
good everything nicely coordinated so it
should be
possible to convert in that time
you should be to next
you
you
now I let the clock run down
oh man it is safely covered
you
you
ninety-seven
okay I really
far too long them yeah I mean I don't
really like this it's the night is on a
bed square and so on the kid should have
for a plate like everything instantly
see one rupee and something like that
night after 7:00 Knight f3 not shown
that the engine gives night d3 as well
this is something that I would have
liked to play but I stopped after I saw
that this is hanging ok the engine of
course calculates further and sees that
this is good for white
you have to agree am Jim look at this
and just get this back it's better for
whitey okay I just went back and played
the nor moose it took it and now we six
that look so terrible
okay a five is even better than ninety
five just like crazy and now I took far
too long for this I mean it just looks
like I should win a piece or something
but I didn't see how this this this
ninety-seven they didn't see how I'm
immediately winning I saw this and
quindi eight and then I felt a maybe
this is not so clear here the night iam
but the engine is pretty cool about it
just plays this and says I'm winning
okay okay ultimately I went with Quinn
before already been down to thirteen
seconds he played a five move data I
didn't even remotely consider
I was thinking he would play here
I have to have to play here play this
yeah it's winning but it looks so odd
now when they played a five giving me
that square and now you're just losing
losing a piece I mean how did you keep
everything hmm
this is just losing a piece and
ninety-eight people on the job now one
thing that is really important is you
have to be a little bit you have to be a
bit very about allowing it to trade on
d5 and the night is on d7 I'm not sure
that it is so terrible here but it's not
desirable at all because on the C file
I'm always going to be a bit more
dangerous here I'm a bit quicker and the
night is active here whatever it is it's
very passive so it's not something that
I would advise doing okay guys thanks
for watchin watching